on the hill tonight for the giants will
be the right-hander logan webb
logan webb 6-1 220 pounder he's 23 years
old as we mentioned from rocklin
california
so here's cole calhoun hit high in the
air down the left field line chasing out
after it is evan longoria the third
baseman and in foul ground he overran
the ball and then lunges back to his
left the ball hits the heel of the glove
and drops away
he was on his own on that one crawford
was over to the right side of second
that's ordinarily a shortstop's ball
doing two pitch swinging in the missy
struck it out
fastball up on the outside
the top of the strike zone let's see if
david peralta can get him home now with
a runner at seven and two men out
fastball down the middle at the knees
strikes recall one hit one left to the
last of the first two men on for the
giants with nobody out yostremski has
faced robbie ray just two times and he's
over two
it's a high drive to left field back is
peralta still back now peralta at the
wallets office glove every base runner
is going to move up one and the bases
are loaded slater's hurting and timeout
is taken head trainer will come out but
they're going to take slater out of the
game
something happened to slater on that
trip from second to third and they've
decided to uh
pull him out of the game here so one out
here is
longoria ground ball down to third
escobar's got it goes to second for one
honda first double play
and robbie ray gets out of it with a
double play ball he struck out flores
and then got the 5-4-3 around the horn
the giants are turned away and the bases
are loaded donovan solano who ripped a
single to left his first time we'll try
it swing and there's a fly ball in the
center field but right there is jay
so the giants are now over five had the
bases loaded in the first and came up
empty and had the bases loaded in the
second and still have not scored
mongoria hitting 250 a pair homer's 11
driven in four doubles and a triple
flora is being held at first the pitch
high drive to left
back is peralta
it is out of here number 300
for evan longoria and the giants take a
two-nothing lead not just pure straight
away left field out toward left center
that was a booming home run
with one out peralta comes up as a tying
run swung on and there is a deep drive
get into right center field back of the
warning track up off the wall ostremski
plays it well walker will score and
peralta's into second base with a double
it's two to one boy you rip that ball
good things happen when you swing the
bat he nailed that ball and hit up the
bottom of the wall i thought that ball
might even sail out of here the giants
did a good job getting it back in and
now escobar swings there's a basic
center field peralta turns third he's
coming to the plate dubon is throwing to
the plate and it's cut off and it's tied
at two so the bats are alive now double
double single and the diamondbacks have
tied this game off webb oh two count on
him and a line draw what a play by
escobar at third the throw to first and
he got him dandy play by escobar you'll
see that on the highlight reel what a
play that was a terrific play and a
great throw fifth walk allowed by robbie
ray and here comes wilmer flores who has
struck out and walked and scored a run
there's a swing and that ball is gone
that is headed for berkeley down the
left field line and
way back into the bleachers wow
what a shot by wilmer flores and the
giants are back ahead four to two
wilmer who struck out with the bases
loaded in the first inning but now he is
the rally it's a one-two count on
donovan salado off reliever kevin ginkel
the pitch with the runner going is a
swing of the miss to throw down and he
got him so a strikeout throw him out
double play will end the ending that
ends
the giant six
strong night so far for logan webb and
he's back for more out number two here
in the seventh inning for the d-backs
hits the target gets strike three call
with the slider seven strong tonight
well done
by logan webb how about this the bases
are loaded for the rookie joey bart
who's playing in his second major league
game
up high ball four bart draws the walk
and a run has scored
that would be his first rbi in the
midways
but he had to earn it it was a 10-pitch
walk to do
his roll very softly right side charging
in from first is
lamb he's going to pick it up and his
only play is to first with garrett
covering he gets to the back put out
crawford but on that play wilmer flores
comes in to score
6-2 so tyler rogers on to pitch the
ninth inning here 15th time that he has
come into a game
well about a week ago his era was about
13 so he's
not quite cut at half but he's whittling
it down
13 strikeouts against a couple walks and
13 innings and that'll bring up steven
vote high to right field did he get it
he did not
and that's the ball dude
the giants take game one